so in this technique we're going to show
you how to get rid of stress on the top
of the neck in order to sleep you have
to have a very relaxed neck and if you
fell on your tailbone or had a neck
injury you definitely want to do this
but these specific points they're right
here in here
our points that are very very relaxing
and if you press into them you can just
press like this right into those little
spots there it's going to release a lot
of stress you can do it yourself there's
two ways you can do it you can do it
sitting or lying down we're going to
show you both ways
so go ahead and put your arms your hands
in the right place there okay good so
you see how she interlocks her fingers
and then she she wants to put her thumbs
I'm gonna straighten the thumb out and
we want the pad right there and right
here okay she's gonna hold that right
there and press into that spot okay and
keep her elbows out here yeah okay she's
gonna hold that for I would say about
two minutes and it's been a little bit
easier if she's laying on down her back
because she's gonna have gravity put the
pressure in there but this you can do it
sitting fine but the as long as the
shoulders are okay sometimes if the
shoulders are too stiff you can't do it
but these two points right here just
underneath the skull pressing directly
in will pull a tremendous amount of
stress off your body there's you can
also do it with a massage tool we'll
show you that in another video but this
is a great thing that you can do before
bed so all these different techniques
we're going to show you do let's say but
do about five minutes before you go to
bed at night and do it every single day
because this is going to pull stress out
of your body as you fill it up through
the day of all that stress you're going
through and that way we can keep the
stress coming off the body okay so this
is this is how you do the first
technique